if you think architectural renders are
hard work and take a lot of time i'm
about to change your mind what's going
on guys my name is david thomich and
welcome back to the channel it's been a
little minute since i've talked to you
in front of this camera so i want to
take the opportunity just to say welcome
to all the new subscribers because today
we're diving in to archicad 25 and twin
motion exactly how you can take a render
and produce high quality architectural
renders so now i'm going to turn around
start the actual timer down below and we
are going to get started with this
tutorial
alright so as hard working david over
there works to show you exactly what you
need to do to be able to produce a
quality 3d render using any archicad
model that you have available to you
basically i'm just going to talk you
through exactly what's happening on that
screen over there as i or him basically
does all the work and you can sit back
and enjoy this quick tutorial so once
you have twin motion open what you're
really looking to do is understand the
site the sun the layout and the
positioning now the key difference
between any architectural render and any
basic boring render is very simple it's
the keen eye of photographer so when
you're actually creating your 3d model
and you're creating your photo renders
you want to be looking for that
photographic quality if you're unsure
what a good photographic scene looks
like take a look at inspirational
pictures look at the angles that they're
looking at look for the different
portions look at the grid lines and set
it up so you know exactly what you're
doing before you start creating anything
so once you have the photo set up in
twin motion and you've saved that first
view there's a couple things you want to
do first of all you want to make sure
that your settings are correct i'm going
to be posting this to instagram so i'm
going to want to be able to post it as
an instagram format instagram is 4x5
which makes it relatively easy for me
personally i export all my photos four
thousand by five thousand pixels because
it gives me enough leverage and enough
pixel density to edit that later in
lightroom if you don't have that much
computing power and your computer can't
handle it drop it down to two thousand
by two and a half thousand and you still
get instagram ready shots directly out
of twin motion now continuing on with
the photographer theme you wanna make
sure that your camera settings are set
up correctly camera settings are
actually pivotal here because it defines
what the actual eye can see so by
default twin motion is set up to a 90
degree field of vision which is very
close to the human eye however in
photography that doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to be a pretty picture
for us it wants to be anywhere below 60
somewhere near that 40 to 60 range
usually i like to compress it down to
about a 50 millimeter lens because it
gives you a nice depth of field and
you're able to create as much
photographic realism in 50 degree field
of view if you want to take it to the
next step you really want to be looking
for better plants and better people and
better cars so you can definitely buy
some better plants online twin motion
does not handle plants very well it
crashes pretty quickly so i tend to try
and avoid any 3d external plants however
i do import most of my other external
objects cars especially are critical
people will look at a render and go oh
my god there's a tesla that's a great
render i'm going to like that image or
oh my god there's a porsche there great
i love that image by the time they
actually see it on instagram or on
tiktok it's long gone because they're
not looking at the finer details if
you're doing a professional render
obviously you take a bit more time but
for instagram and for any social media
platform find the right car find
something trending included in if you're
doing an office render include a brand
new imac include something from apple or
make it relatable to anybody in the
world you want to make sure that the
background and the foreground are as
realistic as possible so personally what
i like to do is actually
enhance the road as much as possible
using a series of materials to be able
to bring that road perfectly in line
with what i'd like it to be then
introducing individual curbing elements
through the bridged items and
introducing elements like footpaths
sidewalks actual painted on grass so 3d
grass plants and objects the like what
really sets it apart is the objects you
use so the plants in twin motion are
half decent and most of the time you can
get away with using just them after the
settings it is really about the
materials you select and how you go
about them right now twin motion has a
series of faults that are really
annoying so sometimes you have to scale
up individual axises rather than scaling
the whole material itself because you
might place on a timber material for
example and it might be completely
warped so don't go running away from
that material straight away and instead
actually try adjust those axes to be
able to produce the best quality render
the one thing lacking in twin motion is
the glass and the quality of the
reflection still most of the time if you
do have a powerful machine then ray
tracing will definitely help with the
glass material as well
twin motion has a variety of materials
that you can directly import through the
bridge or through twin motion itself or
you can import new materials yourself
all of which are critical to making a
good photographic realistic render at
the end of the day and last but not
least the only advice i can give is pay
attention to the details anything that
you model in archicad make sure that you
simply pay attention to those details
because the details make the render so
much better if it isn't for the details
they're going to pick up on a very basic
white wall it's going to look very
boring and very bland and like everybody
else's so if you basically take all of
these tips that i've given you today and
translate them to any rendering software
any program you're going to be able to
basically create some of the best
renders you've ever done in your life so
far and if you really want to take it to
that next level once you've exported it
out of twin motion you want to take it
in to lightroom or any photo editing app
personally i use lightroom i'm an adobe
guy i've used it for a long time so i
know how to edit on it very quickly i
also have my own presets which are
available down below if you want to take
a look but basically i'll throw them
into lightroom and slowly adjust all the
elements to make that render really
really pop because the render quality
that you get out of twin motion is good
but the second it comes out of lightroom
with a few adjustments it's a hundred
million times better anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video if
you did you know the drill hit the
subscribe button hit the like button and
as always i'll see you next monday
[Music]
you